wie bitte den urknall gab es nicht und
stattdessen den bounce was bitte ist das
denn das meint jedenfalls professor paul
steinhart inhaber der albert einstand
professor an der princeton university in
den usa
seiner ansicht nach gibt es zahlreiche
physikalische probleme bei einem urknall
die aus der urknalltheorie ein wahres
kuddelmuddel machen wieso weshalb warum
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
eigentlich gibt es keinen zweifel daran
dass universum ist aus einem urknall
entstanden und nach dieser unglaublichen
explosion hat sich unser universum
geredet vor 13,8 milliarden jahren doch
der urknall macht probleme mit
entwickelt hat diese theorie professor
paul steinhart inhaber der albert
einstein professor an der princeton
university in den usa einer der
renommiertesten physiker weltweit doch
er ist unzufrieden mit seiner theorie
der inflations theorie es hat einfach
hinten und vorne auf den ersten blick
hielten wir inflation für eine elegante
und einfache lösung doch wie so oft
steckt der teufel im detail
das problem des urknalls ist das was in
dem moment dieses kanals passiert die
quantenmechanische effekte die in
unserem ausgedehnten universum nahezu zu
vernachlässigen sind die führen dort zu
einer unmöglichkeit es würden sich
zahlreiche universen bilden deren
unwahrscheinlichkeit oder
wahrscheinlichkeit gleich ist ein
multiversum und das ist fatal es gebe
keinerlei möglichkeiten irgendetwas
vorauszusagen beziehungsweise aus diesem
ereignis schlüsse auf unser universum zu
ziehen
wie schon albert einstein sagte gott
würfelt nicht und genau das passiert
wenn die quantenphysik zum tragen kommt
albert einstein fand diese theorie
damals gar nicht gut und die kosmologie
möchte auf keinen fall eines von vielen
universum was so oder so sein könnte mit
einer gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit nur
auf keinen fall und die astrophysik
spielt ihnen in die hände
dennoch sind keinerlei
gravitationswellen aus der
entstehungszeit des universums gefunden
worden so genannte primo die aale
gravitationswellen und die müsste es
geben wenn es den urknall gegeben
deshalb forscht paul steinhart jetzt
nachdem bauens den helder inzwischen für
die wahrscheinlichere erklärung für die
entstehung des universums und es wäre
dann gar nicht die entstehung des
universums gewesen stattdessen würde
sich unser universum ausdehnen und
wieder zusammenziehen und das eben zu
einem winzig kleinen punkt oder sogar zu
einer singularität also einen punkt ohne
ausdehnung entscheidend ist aber jetzt
die art und weise der ausdehnung die
erfolgt nämlich laut seiner hypothese
vergleichsweise langsam jedenfalls so
langsam dass keine quanteneffekte zum
tragen kommen es entsteht kein
multiversum sondern eben nur unser
einziges homogenes universum mit all den
tollen eigenschaften die vorhersagbar
sind yahoo
demnach gibt es eben kein multiversum
sondern unser universum das quasi von
bounce zu bauens atmet und sich immer
wieder zusammenzieht und ausdehnt immer
und immer wieder
dann gäbe es auch nur schwache primor
die aale gravitationswellen uns wäre
erklärbar warum wir sind noch nicht
gefunden hätten einst scheint mehr immer
deutlicher zu werden wir stehen an einem
scheidepunkt der astrophysik paul
steinhart hat 2007 zahlreichen
vorhersagen über entdeckung gemacht die
es bereits vor fünf jahren hätte geben
sollen entdeckung der dunklen materie
herstellung von dunkler materie
erklärungen der herkunft der dunklen
energie die erforschung des urknalls und
ob es ihn überhaupt gegeben hat und die
entdeckung von gravitationswellen nur
eine seiner vorhersagen ist eingetreten
mit verspätung die entdeckung der
gravitationswellen in allen anderen
fragen sind wir kein müll weitergekommen
nichts mehr
pustekuchen ja vielleicht sind wir bei
diesen themen einfach auf dem holzweg
und liegen vollkommen falsch oder wir
sind sogar an unsere grenzen gestoßen
werden wir vielleicht nie erklären
können woraus die dunkle materie besteht
woher die dunkle energie kommen der
urknall oder rebounds hier bei pixum
werde es jedenfalls erfahren wenn ihr
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
dürfen wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch immer über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken big bang theory urknall
aufgedeckt naja laut steinhart wäre das
dann ein irrtum gewesen aber seht euch
selbst hat ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dann